hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
host genetics with the new axiom human
genotyping sars kobe 2 research array
my name is andrea klein and i'll be your
moderator
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
this is the first topic in the new
webinar series on
predictive genomics for population and
personalized health
for more information on our sponsor
please visit www.thermofisher.com
all right let's get started i would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time during the presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button also please
notice you can share this webinar on
your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's event
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation you can click
on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credit you can click on the continuing
education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
shantanu kaushiker
director of product marketing for
microarray genotyping
at thermo fisher scientific for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
for the q a session at the end of the
presentation shantana will be joined by
dr jeremy golib
director for bioinformatics at thermo
fisher scientific
and design lead for the axiom human
genotyping
stars kobe 2 research array antonio i'll
now turn it over to you to begin your
presentation
hello and thank you for the introduction
uh and thank you for attending our
presentation today on the new axiom
human genotyping sars cove to array
in the next hour or so you'll hear from
me about the use of this array
for research in host genetics and
development and vaccines and
therapeutics
in sars cove to infections
the agenda for today and will cover how
thermo fisher is enabling research in
sars cove to impact during past
outbreaks and our role in sars cove to
research efforts
we'll speak about the role of microarray
as a whole genome scalable technology
for rapid research and then we'll dive
into the design
of the new axiom array that reflects a
paradigm shift in
array design to address the threat from
this virus
lastly we'll wrap up with a question and
answer session
thermo fisher has a history of response
in public health crisis
we've worked hard to make a difference
during not just this
sars cove to outbreak but also during
ebola
h1n1 sars and zika 2.
while we are talking about our genetic
analysis solutions
for outbreak research today thermo
fisher also has a hand in ppe
other scientific research tools like
those for protein and cellular analysis
in detection kits and in vaccine
production and clinical trial logistics
we offer a broad range of technologies
for genetic analysis
including whole genome genotyping and
whole transcriptome microarrays
next-gen sequencing capillary
electrophoresis for sanger sequencing
and fragment analysis
and of course real-time pcr microarrays
play a unique role in supporting sars
cove to research
because of their capabilities in whole
genome genotyping
and in whole transcript expression
analysis
here at thermo fisher we are committed
to service science in the battle against
sars cove to infections
we have genetic analysis solutions for
virus sequencing
pathogen detection epidemiological
surveillance
vaccine research and development
and host genetics and population genomic
studies
within host genetics and population
genomic studies
our whole genome microarrays can help
identify host genetic factors
potentially associated with
susceptibility resistance and more
our portfolio of genotyping and gene
expression arrays offer the capability
to get a whole genome view
in vaccine research the microarray
platform can help identify
and study the impact of infection and
potential vaccines on immune response
let's now discuss the role of
microarrays in addressing the challenges
posed to our world by the sars cove to
virus
and how the axiom genotyping platform
can be used for research in host
genetics vaccine and drug development
in this slide shows age gender and
ethnicity
have been reported as prognosticators of
sars cove to
infection susceptibility and severity
but there are a range of other factors
that can impact the severity and
susceptibility to the disease
for example the cdc released the results
of their pathology and pathogenesis
study last week
that highlighted the role of
pre-existing conditions such as diabetes
lung function and cardiovascular disease
in severity of sars cove to infections
other conditions that have been reported
in various studies since the incidence
of this virus
that can have imp that can impact
severity
have been hypertension and cancer to
name a few
for example the nih director's blog
recently mentions
correlation between [ __ ] blood group
types and increased susceptibility to
the disease
vitamin d levels
blood groups and body mass index have
also been implicated
in the severity of the disease
the various outcomes that have been
reported in literature and in news
articles
have included respiratory distress
pneumonia blood clotting loss of smell
to name a few
the challenge for us then is to
understand how to look at the
interaction
between the virus and the human body and
understand the host viral response
the goal is to stratify population by
risk
and accelerate the development of
vaccines and therapeutics
to fight or even slow down the virus
there are multiple confounding factors
when researching host viral response to
sarskoff to infections
there is the dynamics in interplay
between demographics
underlying conditions and then the
severity susceptibility to sarskoff
ii susceptibility to the virus varies in
populations
and here there are several processes
involved in viral binding to the
cellular membranes
the immune systems in each of us respond
differently to the virus
and there are significant gaps in our
knowledge in developing vaccines and
therapeutic treatments
genotyping and genetics can help address
these challenges
to address these challenges we need to
screen genes in several thousands
if not hundreds of thousands of people
there is therefore a need for a low-cost
scalable and fast technology such as
microwaves that can overcome these
challenges
the axiom human genotyping sars cove to
research array was
developed specifically for the purpose
of research into host genetics
the array was designed with the help of
key opinion leaders in this
area several of the institutions and the
individuals that
helped us came from the institutions
that helped contribute to the content
that is
that is are listed here and we would
like to acknowledge their contributions
and efforts
we would also like to acknowledge the
role of the various consortia and the
biobanks such as those listed here on
the left
including the uk biobank finjan million
veteran program
and the spanish biobank
that have continued to publish their
research during this time
some of the content that's included on
the array is from
from the findings of these research
studies
the new axiom human genotyping source
code to research array
includes all of the benefits of of our
modular approach to designing genotyping
arrays
such as a large us grid with
multi-ethnic population coverage
but more specifically this array
includes three new modules
with new and relevant content for
studying susceptibility
severity and immune response the first
module called the sars cov2
susceptibility module
includes structural variants for viral
entry points
and pathways that are associated with
immunity
and information the second module
includes discoveries
and variants associated with chronic
underlying conditions
that are implicated in the severity of
the disease
also included in the module in this
module
are markers covering blood groups and
blood phenotypes
that have been implicated in the
severity of the disease
the third and final module includes
variants to cover regions associated
with
immune response and that are
important in vaccine development and in
pharmacogenomics
for drug discovery and development
the module also includes new content
on immunoglobulin heavy chains locus
this is something that was newly
introduced for the purpose
of immune response
for sars cove to infections we will
cover the modules one at a time in the
next few slides
one of the most important aspects of
this array is that it offers
dense coverage of genes that are most
relevant in sars scope to infections
for example the array offers fine
mapping of ace2
and the tmprss2 genes that are the viral
entry points
there are two pictures shown over here
on this slide
that show the coverage on the axiom
array and then compares
it with the global screening array the
gsa v3
the two pictures show the markers that
are designed on the array and then
overlaid on the gene
as a comparison the global screening
array for example offers only five
markers
on the ace2 gene this is shown in the
bottom picture
and you can see the trace for the global
screening array
in comparison the axiom human genotyping
array
offers 700 more than 750 markers
for this gene providing fine mapping
capabilities
the reason for designing as many markers
on the ace2
and the tmp rss2 gene is so that we can
better understand the facilitation of
the viral binding process with
cellular structures the genes also serve
as druggable targets
and fine mapping can help with research
in both therapeutics and in vaccine
development
the susceptibility research module also
includes
pathways that are most uh that are
valuable in genotyping and gua studies
this is because they allow the
interpretation of variants with respect
to the biological processes
in which the affected genes and proteins
are involved
genotyping markers for pathways
implicated in viral interactions can
help conduct research into cellular
mechanisms
that regulate viral entry infection and
immunity
these pathways also provide insight into
vaccine research
drug gene interactions into antiviral
therapeutics
these pathways and structural variants
were specifically
selected because of their role in immune
response
viral replication inflammation and
immunity including
innate immunity the pathways can help us
decipher
the underlying host genetic differences
and individual responses to the source
of two virus
these are key to deciphering the source
code to
susceptibility uh and severity to the
source code to infections
some of the more important pathways that
i'd like to mention over here
include the not signaling pathway that's
shown in the bottom left
the ifm pathway that's shown at the very
bottom with more than 2600
the foxo pathway with over 2 300 markers
and the nf kappa radar signaling pathway
that is involved in activating genes
immune response
and inflammation the array has coverage
for cytokine genes that are implicated
in cytokine storm
affecting outcome in infections
another example is the inference
signaling pathway which responds to the
presence of cellular changes suggestive
of viral infection
by introducing by inducing numerous
genes involved in inflammation
signaling and immunomodulation to
protect against uncontrolled
infection they interfere with viral
replication by slowing cell metabolism
interfering with membrane formation
required for virus replication
and inducing secretion of cytokines that
promote adaptive immunity
there is a paradigm shift therefore in
how this array was designed
to include the variance for these very
specific metabolic signaling pathways
this slide covers the variance from the
severity
research module it offers coverage of
variants that are associated with
underlying conditions
and the traits that have been implicated
in the severity of the disease
the content includes recommendations
from key opinion leaders and from
peer-reviewed publications the blood
module
that has more than 2000 variants for
example provides the capability
to look at the role of blood groups not
only in susceptibility but also severity
this array offers the capability to make
new associations
while leveraging peer-reviewed content
for the purpose of studying the severity
and source code to infections
the array covers diseases such as copd
asthma lung function diabetes
hypertension stroke heart disease
and so forth
the third and final module offers
coverage of variants that are important
in drug discovery and development in
vaccine development
and in vaccine response
for pharmacogenomics in drug discovery
and development
the array offers more than seven
thousand variants
that offer high evidence and cover
pseudogenes such as the sip2d6
theory also offers variance for
circulating proteins
that are potential depth targets
within the role of vaccine development
this array offers
variants within the immunoglobulin
um heavy chained locus
and microorganisms that are implicated
in the development of vaccines
these more than 12 000 variants are
novel
and are designed on the array for the
sole purpose
of performing vaccine development and
vaccine research
finally the last
set of gradients on this array includes
variants from the hla kir region
that are typically involved in vaccine
response
more than 13 000 variants offer coverage
of the 11 major
histocompatibility complex class 1 and
class 2 loci
and within the hla region they offer two
and four digit resolution
and can be analyzed using the automated
software for imputing hla types from the
genotype data
in summary this slide shows the content
that is essential
to research host response vaccines and
therapeutics
the axiom human genotyping star scope to
research array
includes these three modules the first
module
the susceptibility module includes
structural variants from pathways
research into cellular mechanisms that
regulate viral entry infection and
immunity
it includes fine mapping of genes
that are associated as viral entry
points
the severity module includes disease
associated variants
and can be used to leverage the genetic
associations
that have been implicated in underlying
conditions
the array also includes a large us grid
to discover
new disease associations and then
finally
the third module offers coverage of
structural variants
implicated in immune response and drug
gene interactions
this includes genetics from regions
associated with immune response for
vaccine research
such as the immunoglobulin heavy chain
locus
and then it also includes markers from
pharmacogenes
for drug gene interactions and in
antiviral therapeutics
the axiom human genotyping sarskoftu
research area offers highly relevant
content representing biological
processes
genes and underlying conditions for
research into host genetics vaccines and
therapeutics
the data from this array can be combined
with data from other studies such as
those that have been
run on the axiom platform meta-analysis
with existing studies will allow
the community to develop approaches to
identifying
areas of the human genome that are
involved in both susceptibility and
severity collaborative approaches
through meta-analysis
and data sharing will generate insights
and spark
new ideas to help fight the sars cove to
virus and with that i'd like to thank
everybody and move to the q a session
if you would like to contact us then
please email us
at bioinformatics services
thermofisher.com
or please visit our webpage at the url
that is shown on this slide
thank you
great thank you shantanu for informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar and welcome dr jeremy
golub to the studio if you have a
question you'd like to ask you can do so
now
just click on that ask a question box
located at the far
left of your screen we will answer as
many of the questions as we have time
for and if we run out
you will have your question answered by
the speaker
using the contact information we
provided at the time of registration
okay let's get started our first
question
is given that type a blood has been
found to be at significantly higher risk
than type o
blood does this covet array handle [ __ ]
locus on chromosome 9
hi this is jeremy i can take that
question yeah
in addition to the recent ellinghouse
paper from which we picked up
the the key variants found in that
research
the array offers excellent coverage of
actually all 33
blood group systems in man uh very much
including [ __ ]
in addition to the major subtypes we can
call many of the
uh less common alleles of
a and b as well as o so that locus is
quite well covered
excellent great thank you next question
on the slide discussing pathways are you
also covering
notch signaling pathways and genes
covered
a claim storm
yes we specifically address
notch and the cytokines as well as their
regulatory elements
okay great um this one should be pretty
straightforward when is the array going
to be available
i'll take that uh andrea um so the array
is available today
and uh the way we manufacture the array
is once
once somebody places an order it takes
us about four weeks to make the array
so it should be available if somebody
places an order today should be
available four weeks from now
excellent great oh go ahead
no go ahead that's that's all right all
right great excellent
um okay another one what markers
associated with acute
resp respiratory distress syndrome and
stroke does the array cover
so we have on the array a large number
of variants associated with lung
function
relevant to ards in addition of course
we have the
the cytokines and interferons and the
regulatory pathways
affecting various aspects of acute
respiratory distress
for stroke we have um
many of the published uh g-wasps hits
relating to stroke
as well as a good coverage of the
coagulation pathway
since the connection to stroke here
seems to be primarily unusual
uh blood clotting or unusual degree of
blood plotting
especially in younger patients we were
we took care to cover that pathway
great great um okay next question
there was a recent publication from mvp
that shared variants implicated in
diabetes
across multi-ethnic populations have you
included those variants on the array
um i'll take that andrea thanks for the
question
um yes the so the cdc recently
identified
diabetes as one of the underlying
conditions that affects the severity of
starscope to infections
we did include variants from this paper
that was published in nature
in june the author's first name is wuja
kovic
the millions veteran program cohort
genotyped on the axiom platform was one
of the many used in this analysis
and this paper basically identified 318
new risk loci for type 2 diabetes and
related vascular outcomes
this was among 1.4 million participants
through a multi-ancestry meta-analysis
so these are included in the array
in addition to variants from of course
the nhgri g-was databases and other
peer-reviewed publications
okay great um i'll end on this next
question but just want to remind our
audience that
the questions we were unable to answer
today and those that come in during the
on-demand period
will be answered by shantanu or jeremy
using the email address you provided at
the time of registration
so our last question then is does this
array cover
multi-ethnic populations and if so can
you share more information on what
populations are covered with this array
um i'll take that as well andrea so the
array covers the five ancestral
populations uh this is basically the
european and mixed american african
south asian and east asian populations
and
covers the 26 populations from thousand
genomes
and then in addition there are various
pathways
often are include markers that cover the
multi-ethnic populations
so hopefully that
covers uh gives information on the
populations just want to make an
emphasis that this also covers and mixed
americans such as latino
african populations so very suitable for
uh use around the globe
excellent great well thank you for that
and shantanu do you have
any final comments you'd like to make
before we close
um no i think just a general comment you
know we designed this array
uh sarskofturi for specific reasons i
think if you consider
other general purpose global arrays that
are available out there
then typically there are two challenges
you know a more general purpose array
is often one where genes are selected
based on the etiopathology of other
diseases
and so what happens is it carries the
risk of losing focus and missing regions
that are implicated in
sars cove too and further you know in a
general purpose array that we believe
there's a lack of statistical power so
you end up typing snips that are not of
specific interest to infectious disease
and so
you run the risk of false positive
inflation
the genes on the on the on the other
hand the genes on the axiom human
genotyping sars cove to array were
selected with the very idea of their
involvement in susceptibility and
severity of the
covet 19. so it makes it really ideal
for research in the ethiopathology of
kovite 19.
the last point is we have a promotion
running on this array
until september so if there is
anyone that's interested please reach
out to us
and you know we'll have one of our reps
reach out to you and provide information
excellent great thank you i want to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for submitting their questions
um again any not addressed today will be
answered
um using your contact information
provided
so i'll thank again shantanu for his
time we want to also thank
labruts and our sponsor thermofisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
so lab boots will alert you by email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
and with that we will sign off i hope
everyone has a great day
you